cosa la maestra
Ma che bello finalmente le vacanze non
mi devo preoccupare di niente posso solo
rilassarmi Evviva finalmente
[Musica]
Ma questo è il telefono di Anita Con
questo posso costringerla a fare le mie
Challenge
venite a vedere
Ehi Anita
Billy che cosa ci fai qua e Riconosci
questo è il tuo telefono dammelo No non
fare un altro passo lo butto
Ma vedi nessuno voleva giocare con me e
io mi stavo annoiando e quindi sono qui
ho preso il tuo telefono e lo butterò
qui in piscina lo farò affogare se tu
non farai le mie Challenge no
tutti gli oggetti che io ho sparso nella
piscina ma stai attenta Non prendere le
alghe oppure il tuo telefono
affogato
affogato affogato che cosa al cioccolato
alla vaniglia all'amarena Oh sì che
bello Dove dove
Ale
ma cosa ci fai là
hai il mio cellulare vuole buttarlo in
acqua fermo Vitale non fare un altro
passo Sì sì guarda che la butto eh
Guarda che lo sto per buttare in acqua
Eh devo trovare un modo per aiutare
Anita
e vitale tornate dentro casa dovrebbe
venire qua ad aiutarmi e va bene
recupererò tutti questi oggetti Allora
stando attenti a non toccare le alghe
pronto via
[Musica]
ho preso il primo oggetto un delfino
giallo
[Musica]
ho preso il secondo oggetto un cuore blu
ho trovato il terzo oggetto Il Delfino
Blu chissà quanti aggettivo mancheranno
adesso
devo trovare qualcosa per aiutare Anita
[Musica]
Qui non c'è niente
Forse ho trovato qualcosa
questa una maschera subacquea forse la
aiuterò ci devo provare andiamo
[Musica]
No ma mi hai trovato un altro
troppo facile questa Challenge l'ho
fatta troppo facile ma vedi Anita So io
come farla più difficile ti lancerò
altre alghe dentro quella piscina
Aspettami lì Uffa altre anche no devo
sbrigarmi a trovare tutti gli oggetti
prima che torni con altre alghe presto
ed ecco le altre alghe Adesso sì che la
sfida sarà più difficile
Ehi ma l'avete sentito questo significa
forse è chiarita ho toccato le alghe
devo buttare il telefono andiamo
Che cos'è questo rumore
[Musica]
[Risate]
Ma che brutto quel ballo
come me Dovrei ballare se dalla maestra
non vorrei farti picchiare
e sai dov'è È proprio lì Guarda cosa lo
maestro
ti ho fregato Ciao Billy Prova a
prendermi adesso Ah ci son cascato senti
prendo te la faccio vedere io Sì ciao
sono le Emoji di Anita e volevo
chiederti hai già cliccato mi piace
sotto questo video Se non hai ancora
cliccato mi piace Clicca subito mi piace
qua sotto
e Ciao io sono Vitale Ti sei già
iscritto al canale se non l'hai fatto
Iscriviti adesso e clicca anche sulla
campanellina
[Applauso]
Eh questo
una maschera in Italia mi ha lanciato
una maschera per vedere meglio
sott'acqua Ora sì che posso completare
la Challenge velocissimamente Andiamo
[Musica]
con questa maschera Scusate benissimo
ho trovato tutti gli esercizi li ho
collezionati tutti questo vuol dire che
ho vinto la prima Challenge
No digli Mi dispiace per
Billy
Vitale
sono finiti quei due devo dirgli che
aumentano la prima Challenge
Billy Vitale
[Musica]
e adesso
e adesso ti picchio
ti prego ti vuoi prendere il gioco di me
ancora
io ho vinto la prima Challenge quindi
Lascialo in pace ok
Hai capito bene Ho vinto la prima
Challenge ho trovato tutti gli oggetti
non ci posso credere tu mi hai distratto
e lei è finita la Challenge No mi
dispiace Bubi Sei una schiappa che devo
fare
scherzavo scherzavo Ah Vitto la
Challenge E va bene Avrei vinto questa
Challenge Ma nella prossima non
sopravvivrai seconda Challenge
[Musica]
adesso per questa Challenge Questa sarà
la più epica mega iper ultra Challenge
più difficile di questo pianeta e
infatti Guardate cosa c'è in piscina e
cosa qualcosa in piscina
oggi non c'è niente in piscina
[Musica]
l'ho rubato all'acquario Come io sono il
bullo delle scuole lui è il bullo dei
mari l'ho trovato lì all'acquario in una
vasca d'acqua e nessuno lo voleva tutti
avevano paura di lui e come tutti hanno
paura di me ma lui voleva solo
divertirci al massimo mangiare sbranare
quel qualche pesce qualcuno niente di
che ma che cosa stai dicendo Sei
impazzito Siamo proprio in sintonia
siamo troppo amici in cui io ho pensato
perché non portarlo da niente Vitale
Almeno ci divertiamo insieme e adesso in
questa Challenge tu Anita dovrai
scappare dal mio sharky e lui ti seguirà
e non con molta pietà via
[Musica]
ma è troppo divertente
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Giorgio
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Mettetevi
Oh no Povera Mica lo squalo sta
arrivando
[Musica]
si è fermato lo squalo si è fermato
Anita Anita lo squalo si è fermato
[Musica]
se rimango immobile non mi insegue Ho
capito ho capito se rimani ferma lo
squalo si ferma no
stupido come hai fatto a capirlo è vero
Il mio sharky non vede ma questo non
significa che non possa sentirla Anche
perché è una piscina non è al mare non
potrà sfuggire per sempre
Allora non mi resta che rimanere
immobile e sperare che non mi senta Ma
se non posso muovermi Come faccio a
scappare da questa piscina con lo squalo
Ehi
capitare che c'è Non preoccuparti
pennelli si distrae proverò a buttarla
in piscina Hai capito Sì ma stai attento
zio
riuscire a buttare Billy nella piscina
quando senti il mio segnale scappa dalla
piscina
Ma quante ne accorgerai Non ti
preoccupare capirai che il mio segnale
Ok ok va bene sbrigati però Ok a dopo
[Musica]
Aiuto Speriamo che davvero non mi veda
devo rimanere completamente immobile e
speriamo che Vitale abbia un piano per
aiutarmi Uffa così non vale Anita è
ferma e cerchi non riesci a vederla Oh
devo fare qualcosa io devo dargli la
carica al mio al mio amato Sharko
cerchi piccolo mio Adesso ti faccio il
tifo e ti do un po' di
cerchi Cerchi cerchi Shark Shark
Shark
mar piccolo piccolo mio
cerchi Vai Shark
primo dentista
in quel momento giusto per scappare era
mia vita Vieni fuori
sbrigati no Mi avete fregato No vabbè ma
tanto il mio cerchio a me non fare
niente Dove sei cerchi Fatti vedere
cerchi
io non si sta facendo vedere da me
piccolo mio Ah eccoti Ciao sharky No non
mi guardare così no mi guardare così no
no no no fai una brava squadra Bravo
bravo
[Musica]